boa tarde a todos e todas as
dificuldades que ele vai realmente eu
não sou substancial a minha popular
fiz um estado ainda é possível
experimentar outra outra casa que ainda
vai sempre roupa na hora de comprar o
que cansa estudo combinar um título ir
para um reflexo é uma coisa muito
complicada tem mais produtos falando um
monte de 200 nada não é importante o que
vemos no mês que saberá que não é por
acaso que o nosso principal formado em
direito ou mostrar a quem não quero ter
sempre postal
falei muito e não faço há pouco em
londres que estava cansado mas está ok
você sabe para lá conosco enquanto um
professor de direito penal em pinhais na
não se cansa de elogiar a favor do corpo
e que acha que dá aulas não é apenas
transmitir conhecimento não é e eu isso
neste aspecto estão acompanhado pela
noiva para o pessoal dos meus colegas
estamos na universidade
miguel mas o número final
aqui é um lugar direto trata das sanções
mais pesadas que o palmeiras é apenas
material não está simplesmente nós temos
de transmitir aos nossos doentes aos
mais do que isso é e foi nessa
perspectiva que há uma frase mas que
igualmente foi um grande grande filósofo
constituído é filósofo porque mesmo a a
presente década sobre a felicidade
bilhão nos nove anos que quiser
sendo que o futuro não é totalmente nós
nem tal não nós o importante é que eu
dizia é que dizia é que fizera filipe
silva e viramos outros operadores nesta
tarde
é isso mesmo o futuro do cruzeiro aqui
no maior lembrou que nós fizemos e abson
fato ecológico e dizia que somos nós o
carro com o autor dos livros curso e é
também do erro que vos vai me falar aqui
numa visita que fiz ao sistema prisional
do porto custóias mas que se não é
somente vôos toy as novas saiu o atleta
quer uma coisa básica daí eu sei quantos
deles foram descobertos ainda faz calor
e todos nessa sala do terminal num clima
ou seremos potenciais criminosos
as aulas vão acontecer caso um tema que
é o que é importante é que o
investimento dos recursos poderá
ajudá-los está muito ligado a uma coisa
que todos nós enquanto eu já me
perguntaram por que o estado apenas
morte do livro bava como pena a multa
como o céu em vários fóruns que nós com
a nossa imaginação sempre maquiavélica
algumas histórias fomos inventando para
punir alguém que quer uma regra
nós temos uma série de teorias não é seu
filho espeto sala que não dirá uma coisa
eu acho
é preciso distribuir o mal fez uma lata
unidade tem de pagar para que o mal eu
acho que levo unir para tentar que esta
pessoa se ele insistir nas viradas
quiserem nós nunca podemos obrigar
ninguém a vencer isso acho que é punir
para afastar os outros deveria cometer
um crime por exemplo são três ou quatro
publicações que nós não trabalhamos em
que vai mudar vai me dar nenhuma
explicação mais ou menos científica do
que é o que está mais atrasado isso
queria e foi incluído nos vemos e
profissional de moda não é hoje em dia
há coisas para nós são duas vítimas mas
por exemplo os estados unidos
em alguns casos é concebível que uniu 12
anos e já é considerado o maior elefante
finais e alguns anos atrás tem retornado
à pena de morte por exemplo estamos a
falar do estado é supostamente o estado
mais emblemático em termos de democracia
quando fazem as vezes que não fez um
caso curioso só que avalia aspectos mais
gravosos pelas mais complicados mas
nesta comédia tranqüilo foi convidado
para falar connosco luso depois foi
normal e civic é a mesma para quem
aproveitar consultas larga não é
problema do galo deixa eu te perguntar
no processo em que é o que quero fazer
um bom jogo para 3 claro que procurei
falar sempre nos traz também não podia
até produções blog dicas em outros
países ou julgados ou tentado aquilo mas
depois dessa conversa com ela quer
procurar moro quatro horas
quem não votar o andamento tanto os
comportamentos estado até se estavam
está longe de fazer uma visita ao resto
do estabelecimento prisional no dia
conhecer é isso foi há cerca de dois
anos atrás
nesta visita para sair por um espaço de
uma década e perguntar ao diretor que
estava a acompanhar essas coisas gosta
de estar sempre a dizer não é assim para
do boxe com a campanha visa
visitamos o seu diretor michel soltou na
nossa gente tem que cuidar uns
outono/inverno mãe é quem não vou fazer
30 vezes doutor na época mas ela
significa nada
é uma coisa que nós temos volta ao
colégio dizer o caminho justo é um bicho
raro é uma coisa muito estranha deve ter
tempo bom está em vantagem mas passei
muito da biblioteca é exemplo de ter sim
principalmente regionais
olha a bola record os mais produtivos
a maioria não chega lá nega ter aquela
parte maio do diário por ligar para ela
esse é mais um incêndio
é um livro pra isso mas é um salto temos
aqui você reclusos que gosta do milho
subiram até que representam livros e
possui 50 bairros era todos que estão
fazer seus cursos surpresas dentro do
sistema prisional meramente foi o
irritar a aula livre de drogas
quem é realmente uma boa parte dos jogos
algumas histórias que é um modelo de
negócio de luta que temos windows não há
realmente é um sentimento falava pouco
anda também detectamos o estado social
não temos livros desde tempos antigos a
obra mais ou menos normal não valem o
primeiro água lixo e dizimam outra sim
há uma uma taxa social inicial e assim e
tal aí nós temos falta de roupas roupas
legal
nós sabemos o que estava com a seleção
das penas
o estado tem a obrigação de pensar não
quer obviamente mais da alimentação
vestuário recentemente no estado mas não
é exata
depois da prática que está acontecendo
vem da crise de 2008 nós sabemos que
quem está sem falar em crise
é eu quero estar lá da crise é tema do
formado imagino eu estiver a pensar mas
quem sou católico mas dizia ela tem
circulado com as roupas porque realmente
as pessoas não é só a família usava as
roupas que começou no bar porque não
tinha possibilidades para fazer tudo e
muito calor
é uma história que eu ia fazer uma coisa
muito simples
todos nós jogamos todos quase todos
temos uma página na internet uma página
na internet todas aquelas coisas a quem
gosta de fotografar o tac - quando
adiantou agora estou na casa de banho
bárbaro na campanha e criar uma página
eu não vai existir um livro na prisão
uma janela para o povoado foi
precisamente nós sabemos que o eleitor é
um espaço de bazar é um espaço que nós
temos qualquer o nosso time estar numa
cadeira de rodas problema está numa cana
perde isso não é de todos aqui é o céu
do galego que lutou corajosamente
ouviram morte digna é e eu disse isso
mesmo que quando escrevia quando
visitava seus poemas quando ia ser igual
a caminhar pelo pelo imenso quando vai
em toda a costa da galiza pensando um
pouco nisso eu não passo nem com vez
meus amigos não fez o livro o menino
máximos a pressionar o santa cruz do
bispo
pensei que seria uma coisa simples né
foram os nossos amigos para desta página
é muita gente e chegamos é uma cerveja
com a questão social é porque também
prega um prego bancada do porto que eu
acho que o livro que acusa quatro letras
não continue sujando a imagem da
impressionante então começamos a ele
as provisões aos casos cabe usar com a
questão social escrita e consegui provar
esta ideia de uma coisa ruim e de volta
para os nossos sistemas prisionais e
aquilo que os observava o objetivo de
apenas recolher dos seus profissionais
acabou com mais de 10 mil livros com
vários quilos roupa mas a senhora não
criamos em finanças externas 90 são mais
cuidar eu vou sair mais roupa no site
novamente quebraram nos coloca no site
conseguiu distribuir depois ninguém
foram algumas câmaras municipais que vêm
ter connosco foi a fundação nacional
foram todas as populares do estado
importa foram famosas todos os consoles
esteve estamos gratos à reitoria está
foi bastante esta iniciativa que termina
fmi no dia que todos os cenários como
saber exatamente o que devia ter sido
feita mas a direção geral necessários
três personagens como samba entender
claro uma na publicidade
a grande dificuldade que eu estou certo
que a entidade foi exatamente agora é
campanha o senhor sabe fazer a campanha
porque eu sabia do trabalho
o jovem estava no lado externo do corpo
pode pedir a autorização para ser o
cidadão ativo né
na história do chefe quem quiser não
produzo poços o que também está a fazer
porque mas tem o propósito fazer com que
o preço
nós sabemos que ele virou um país como o
nosso com recursos limitados como três
nas costas
os esquecidos os esquecidos que estavam
na curuzu
mesmo sendo que 15 mil angolanos em
portugal 15 mil votos e não voltam todos
convivem tamanho deve pensar agora que
só pra te ver pra não voltar mais ao
onze que foi então foi positivo que
outro lado teve cerca de 15 mesma coisa
mesmo que vão ficar juntos por três ou
quatro posto com os familiares mais
próximos não são votos
não é um tema da campanha nós vamos
claro como é que vamos tratar os nossos
recursos
vamos construir mais prisões não vamos
vamos querer que os outros países que
tentam pintar as meninas alternativas à
prisão quem fala isso não dá voto
o time atual que essa não seja uma
preocupação do estado é transmissão
geral é entendia que isto era realmente
um marco no ensinar
eu estava a chamar a atenção para uma
eficiência do sistema
então foi sempre uma grande potência em
prováveis entre que estou sobrando é só
imaginar prudentes cana direções como
base entrar não é história
levantava os grandes problemas não só de
seu reitor que a empresa não há janela
importante foi isso que foi feito e está
a dar maturidade
então aquilo que é mais uma vez que é
que seus profissionais devem estar
abertos à comunidade
acabou por ser exatamente o contrário
bom infelizmente nós não fizemos o
evento na faculdade e grande
o grande estrela foi que eu estava na
direita é que eu fui que é o sistema
prisional do porto
nós éramos dois minutos foram usadas
autorizada depois muita gente a e foi um
realmente a figura mais amplo da casa
foi o que falou o tratamento da imprensa
e 1.500 empregos lá dentro a gente
preocupada e conseguir um pacto
tranqüilo sem roupa por todos os seus
profissionais do nosso país portugal
continental nós temos as ilhas mas enfim
não sei que o futuro se consiga duas
outras coisas não temos um limite
entretanto a todo o movimento esse que
está puxando essa é o padre joão
gonçalves a um documentário
imaginava implantaram menezes eu tenho
problema agora é repetir quiseram
comentar chamado por para as prisões
vale a pena ver porque estava em campo
também é franzina fazer esse apoio
também ao juntos assim que eu acho que
ela está à guarda sério agora brincado
que os blocos que é um tempo que faz
isto leva poesia aos seus filhos no
ginásio vai ler poesia para juntos
discutindo por dia com ela que ganha 0
quem nada faz disputar o voluntariado é
que temos um exemplo a noruega mas não é
preciso montar nos estressando gostamos
nós podemos ter é isso que nós vemos
bastante no final não é isso que nós
queremos e devemos tratar os nossos usos
como pessoas de sá
o emprego vais levar gols vamos
tratá-los como espécies animais muitas
vezes diziam então você está a tratar
dos reclusos até mesmo retalhos que
venciam espanhola tantas vezes já muita
gente que trata de simplesmente são
tomadas tanto nossa pois o joão zwetsch
nós vamos lembrar os judeus
eu fico com essa citação do álbum kers
porque nós noite foi morrendo um
inquérito internacional autor nossas
mensais e audi entre outras coisas em
que nós não podemos ser visto em breve
ser força universal
não podemos ser reforçada em bissau
quando devemos tentar ser um beijo
momentâneo no shopping noturno das
coisas que fazem cada vez mais percebo
que o resto é ruído e poderão trabalhar